Guten Abend, mein Name ist Esdemir. Ich bin auf dieser Station zuständig gewesen für Sie heute und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen. Wäre es in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, ja. Hauptsache jemand schaut nach meinem Jungen. Ich bin hier mit meinem Sohn.
Ja, okay. Verstehe. Bevor Sie mir Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden erzählen, würde ich Ihre persönlichen Daten erfassen. Und wie heißen Sie bitte?
Also ich heiße Elisabeth Engel, aber mein Sohn um den es geht, der heißt Marvin Engel.
Und ja, sind Sie krank oder? Mein Sohn ist krank.
Mein Sohn und Ihr Sohn ist krank. Und könnte ich bitte Ihren Sohn erst mal seinen Namen beschreiben?
Ja, der Vorname ist Marvin. M-A-R-V-I-N. Marvin. Und der Familienname ist Engel. E-N-G-E-L.
Engel am Anfang? E wie Emil oder? E wie Emil oder E wie Engel, ja.
Engel. Beide sind E wie Emil oder die zweite E wie Ida?
Nein, auch E. Engel. E-L am Ende. Engel, okay. Verstehe. Wie heißen Sie? Ich brauche auch Ihren Namen.
Ich heiße Elisabeth Engel.
Elisabeth, wie schreibt man das? E-L-I-S-A-B-E-T-H.
Ja, okay, verstehe. Und ja, Frau Engel, könnten Sie mir sagen, was hast du zu uns geführt?
Wir können Ihnen helfen. Danach würde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihren Sohn fragen oder zu Ihnen fragen stellen.
Naja, es geht ja um meinen Sohn. Der ist krank. Und zwar hat er schon...
Und wie alt ist er? Wie alt ist er? Er ist neun Jahre alt.
Neun Jahre alt. Und verraten Sie bitte sein Geburtstatum?
Ja, ist der 5.2.2017.
Der ist gerade neun geworden.
Gut. So, nach hier. Geburtstatum. Und ja, wissen Sie, wie groß ist er?
Da ist er 1,31 Meter.
Und wie viel wiegt er?
Ja, also das letzte war 28 Kilo.
Okay. Was hast du zu uns? Und wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, der Marvin ist im Augenblick gar nicht gut drauf. Der hat ständig Durchfälle.
Also bestimmt zwei-, dreimal in der Woche, dass er so ganz wässrigen Stuhl hat.
Und ja, dann hat er auch Bauchschmerzen. Und dann mag er auch irgendwie gar nicht essen.
Und ja, also der ist schon ein ich lange so ein bisschen schlecht drauf.
Und ich hab erst immer gedacht, ja, das ist vielleicht, dass er nicht gerne zur Schule geht.
Und deswegen so tut, als ob er krank ist oder so.
Aber jetzt hab ich dann gemerkt, dass er auch wirklich ordentlich abgenommen hat.
Der hat früher drei Kilo mehr gewogen. Der hat immer 31 Kilo gewogen.
Und jetzt wiegt er nur noch 28. Und wie ich das gemerkt habe, habe ich mich schon ein bisschen erschrocken.
Und was mir auch aufgefallen ist, dass er ziemlich oft auf die Toilette geht.
Und seit neuestem, das ist auch noch nicht so lange, gehen ihm ziemlich stark die Haare aus.
Für so einen kleinen Kerl ist das natürlich irgendwie ganz komisch.
Und ich meine, ja, der Marvin ist schon immer so mein Sorgenkind eigentlich gewesen.
Der hat schon von klein auf, ist der zuckerkrank.
Der hat also schon von klein auf Diabetes und bekommt Insulin.
Und da muss ich natürlich gucken, und da sind wir ständig beim Kinderarzt.
Aber jetzt diese Geschichte da mit diesen Durchfällen und mit den Bauchschmerzen.
Und der ist auch so schlapp. Und in der Schule, sagt die Lehrerin, ist er, ja, der kann sich gar nicht gut konzentrieren.
Und wirkt irgendwie so, als ob er gar nicht da wäre.
Also das macht mir jetzt inzwischen schon wirklich große Sorgen.
Ok, verstehe, ja, Frau Engel. Ja, ich verstehe ganz vollkommen Ihre Sorge und Ängste.
Aber ja, Sie sind bei uns in guten Händen und wir machen alles, was Ihr Sohn weiter gut wird.
Jetzt ja, Sie haben erwähnt eine Durchfälle.
Und wieviel Mal muss er auf die Toilette gehen? Wissen Sie, haben Sie das bemerkt?
Ja, also an den Tagen, wo er Durchfall hat, da geht er bestimmt 3-4 Mal hintereinander.
Aber das ist nicht jeden Tag.
Haben Sie den Stuhl gesehen? Natürlich, das ist ganz wässrig, das ist wie Wasser.
Weiß ich. Aber vielleicht noch eine Blutbeimengung drin, haben Sie bemerkt oder hat geklagt?
Rot war da nichts drin, würde ich sagen. So sah das nicht aus. Blutig war das nicht.
Auch die Farbe der Stuhl, vielleicht ein bisschen heller oder dunkler.
Also eher heller. Bisschen schwarz.
Ne, schwarz war da nichts.
Eher hell.
Und auch schleimig vielleicht ein bisschen.
Ein bisschen schleimig auch dabei, aber eigentlich eher so wässrig.
Tritten diese Durchfälle nach einem etwas Essen? Gibt es einen Zusammenhang mit dem Essen oder eine bestimmte?
Ja, neulich war es ganz schlimm. Da hatten wir Spaghetti gegessen und da ging es ihm ganz schlecht hinterher.
Aber er ist sowieso ein ganz schlechter Eßer. Er isst nicht gerne Obst und Gemüse.
Er ist natürlich auch genervt durch diese Zuckerkrankheit, dass er da eben vorsichtig essen muss.
Obst und Gemüse isst er nicht gerne.
Ist das eine Verbindung mit Kohlenhydrate oder nur Spaghetti mit Soße?
Vielleicht hat eine Soße eine Verbindung?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt... Wir alle anderen haben keine Beschwerden gehabt hinterher.
Okay. Und haben Sie schon erwähnt, ein abgenommen Gewichtverlust von 3 kg? In welchem Zeitraum hat er das?
Ich würde sagen so ein halbes Jahr.
Und normal in dem Alter wachsen Kinder ja noch und nehmen eher zu.
Okay, stimmt. Fühlte er schlapp und müde? Waren Sie schon mal in anderem Arzt?
Nein, wir waren halt beim Haushalt wegen dieser Zuckerkrankheit. Er ist ja regelmäßig in der Kontrolle.
Aber jetzt mit dieser Geschichte waren wir da noch nicht.
Nein.
Und er spritzt Insulin regelmäßig.
Ja, also da muss ich halt für sorgen.
Ja, ist diese Zuckerkrankheit gut eingestellt bisher?
Ja, die ist gut eingestellt, sagt der Hausarzt.
Und ist ihm übel oder hat er mehrmals erbrochen?
Er hat eigentlich nur keinen Hunger und das ist eigentlich auffällig. Und dass er so ein bisschen schlapp ist.
Und dass eben auch die Lehrerin das in der Schule so beschreibt. Dass er da so desinteressiert ist.
Sein Handy? Ja, manchmal würde ich gerne wissen.
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen. Also habe ich jetzt nicht gesehen. Wüsste ich nicht.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob er eine Hautveränderung hat oder trockene Haut oder vielleicht...
Also er hat schon ziemlich trockenen Haut und zwar an beiden Oberarmen hat er gerade im Augenblick auch so ein bisschen einen juckenden Ausschlag.
Das ist aber ziemlich neu. Das ist erst seit zwei Wochen oder so.
Noch würde ich wissen, ob er eine Schwellung im Halsbereich hat oder vielleicht ein Schluckproblem.
Nee, das hat er zumindest nicht gesagt, dass er beim Schlucken Schmerzen hat oder so.
Eigentlich sagen Kinder, dass sie Halsschmerzen haben oder so. Nee, aber da hat er nichts von gesagt.
Okay, verstehe. Und würde einige Fragen zu seinem Allgemeinszustand stellen.
Hat er Fieber oder Schüttelfrost, einen Schattennachschweiß?
Also ich habe jetzt nicht gemessen, aber der war überhaupt nie fiebrig in den Tagen.
Und schlafte er gut? Schlefte er gut?
Ja, das kommt drauf an. Wenn er gerade Bauchschmerzen hat, schläft er natürlich nicht so gut.
Dann muss ich oft mal nachts noch mal zu ihm kommen und manchmal muss er dann auch in der Nacht noch mal auf die Toilette.
Und das passiert schon, ja. Also schläft er eher nicht so gut.
Sie haben schon erwähnt, ein Problem mit dem Stuhlgang, aber wie sieht es aus beim Wasserlassen?
Vielleicht Schwierigkeiten oder Fälligkeiten beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, er muss halt sehr häufig, er muss ziemlich oft auf die Toilette gehen. Also auch zum Tobi machen.
Auch zum Wasserlassen, ja.
Ich würde gerne mal zu seinem kranken Vorgeschichte übergehen. Und zwar haben Sie schon erwähnt, eine Zuckerkrankheit und unter Kontrolle sprichst du seit Insulin. Und in welcher Dosierung wissen Sie?
Oder habe ich zu Hause den Zettel, das habe ich jetzt nicht mit.
Ja, ich kontaktiere mit dem Kinderarzt.
Abgesehen von dieser Zuckerkrankheit hat er noch eine andere Erkrankung. Leidet er?
Also ja, wie gesagt, jetzt neu dieser komische Ausschlag da. Und dann war er einmal vor zwei Jahren zu einer kleinen Operation in der Klinik.
Da hatte er einen Leistenbruch und das ist operiert worden.
Wann war diese Operation?
Vor zwei Jahren.
Zwei Jahren.
Da war er gerade in der Schule, oder Jan?
Auf der rechten Seite.
Und noch weitere Operationen?
Nein, er ist erst neun Jahre alt. Es ist noch nicht viel passiert zum Glück.
Ja, er ist natürlich schon klein, aber außer Insulin nimmt er vielleicht noch andere Medikamente ein.
Nein, sonst braucht er nichts.
Vielleicht eine Salbe für diese Ausschläge?
Ja, das haben wir versucht mit einer juckreizstillenden Salbe. Aber wie gesagt, das ist erst ganz neu und da hat noch nicht richtig was geholfen.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Ja, ich nehme, er raucht nicht und solche Gewohnheiten natürlich schon klar.
Nee, er ist noch ein bisschen zu klein.
Aber würde ich wissen, vielleicht eine Druckenkonsum hat er nicht auch?
Nein, wie soll er da dran kommen?
Gottes Willen, nein.
Eine Routinefrage natürlich.
Ist bei Ihnen eine Krankheit bekannt? Vielleicht im Familienseite würde ich wissen.
Also ich weiß, dass ich Gallensteine habe und irgendwann mal müssen die operiert werden, aber im Augenblick machen wir da nichts dran.
Gallensteine? Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin geschieden.
Ich würde auch wissen, wie es mit dem Vater aussieht.
Was? Sie meinen wegen Erkrankung?
Ja, wegen Erkrankung.
Er hat hohen Blutdruck, das weiß ich.
Ansonsten eine Nähe in der Verwandtschaft, Großeltern oder vielleicht eine Darmerkrankung hat eine Erklärung.
Nicht, dass ich wüsste. Und er hat auch noch einen großen Bruder und der ist aber gesund.
Er ist gesund, der hat nichts. Ich habe halt irgendwie auch lange gedacht, dass das vielleicht so eine Reaktion ist auf die Scheidung.
Dass er deswegen so ein bisschen nicht in die Schule will und dass ihm das alles unangenehm ist und dass er da nicht darüber reden will.
Aber jetzt ist es irgendwie immer schlimmer geworden.
Verstehe. Ist Ihr Impfstatus vollständig?
Natürlich, der Kinderarzt sorgt schon dafür, dass er gegen alles geimpft ist.
Ja, waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, nein, nein, das schaffen wir gar nicht.
Ja, beziehungsweise Tropen oder Asien vielleicht?
Nein, nein, nein, wir müssen ja hier vor Ort sein und er muss zur Schule gehen, ich muss zur Arbeit gehen.
Also können wir uns gar nicht erlauben, großen Urlaub.
Bisher haben Sie alle Ur-Untersuchungen gemacht, ja, machen lassen.
Ja, ja, doch das gelbe Heft, das ist komplett ausgefüllt, ja.
Ja, wie war denn das letzte Mal in Kinderarzt?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wann die letzte, ich glaube die ist mit nach der Schule, nach der Einschule, ich weiß gar nicht, wann die letzte Untersuchung war.
Ist schon eine Weile her. Aber wir haben das schön nach Plan gemacht.
Und ja, er war dann eben durch den Diabetes, war mal ein bisschen unter der Kurve.
Aber grundsätzlich war er eigentlich immer zufrieden der Kinderarzt mit ihm.
Oh, verstehe.
Ja, damit einige noch Fragen bei Ihnen stellen, ich würde zurück an Amnesi sprechen.
Sie haben durch viele erwähnt, aber habe ich nicht gefragt, vielleicht seit wann haben Sie genau, vielleicht seit mehrere Wochen oder Monaten?
Also er redet davon schon seit einem halben Jahr, aber ich habe das nie so ernst genommen.
Er hat dann oft gesagt, er muss oft auf die Toilette und so.
Und dann habe ich aber das gar nicht so wahrgenommen.
Aber das ist jetzt schon bestimmt ein paar Monate.
Ja, verstehe. Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen, die damit einhergehen in dieser Krankheit?
Oder möchten Sie noch Ergänzungen in diesem Zusammenhang?
Ich habe Ihnen ja jetzt eigentlich viel erzählt.
Ja, dass er ein schlechter Eßer ist und dass er keinen Appetit hat und dass wir mit dem Diabetes halt irgendwie aufpassen.
Am liebsten würde er natürlich die ganze Zeit nur Süßigkeiten essen.
Ja, aber das geht natürlich nicht.
Ja, verstehe.
Also sonst wüsste ich jetzt nicht, was ich Ihnen noch erzählen kann.
Haben Sie schon natürlich unternommen, damit diese Durchfälle lindern oder vielleicht...
Wenn das so war, dann haben wir mal Salzstangen und Zwiebeln gehabt, damit man so ein bisschen den Bauch schont.
Und dann haben wir Kamilientee, das hat er dann getrunken.
Ja, das war dann ja auch eigentlich... Im nächsten Tag war es dann wieder weg oder im übernächsten Tag.
Und dann konnte man ja nicht ständig nur so Schoenkost geben.
Aber empfindet er eine Schmerzen irgendwo? Ja, Bauchschmerzen.
Er hat Bauchschmerzen. Ja, er hat immer wieder Bauchschmerzen.
Aber wie gesagt, ich habe gedacht, das ist nur so eine Entschuldigung, dass er das vorschiebt, weil er keinen Bock hat in die Schule zu gehen.
Ja, können Sie mir vielleicht sagen, in welchem Charakter hat diese Bauchschmerzen?
Ich denke mal, es drückt ihn im Bauch. Er sagt, es drückt ihn im Bauch.
Und das geht auch in den ganzen... Also das strahlt auch irgendwie in den ganzen Bauch rein.
Ja, wie stark sind diese Schmerzen vielleicht?
Das kann ich nicht einschätzen. Das kann ich nicht einschätzen.
Also die sind glaube ich jetzt nicht so schlimm, sonst hätte er ja viel mehr gejammert.
Ja, Frau Engel, vielen Dank für das Gespräch. Das war eine Frage, die ich stellen wollte.
Ja, ich will natürlich wissen, woran liegt es denn jetzt und was können wir dagegen machen.
Und ich will natürlich, dass es dem Kleinen wieder besser geht.
Ja, Frau Engel, natürlich ist es zu früh, eine genaue Diagnose zu entfalten.
Ja, es könnte sich um eine Darmentzündung oder eine Darmerkrankung handeln.
Ja, aber wie ich gesagt habe, ich werde gleich...
Aber wo kommt das her?
Ja, es könnte eine Erdbehebung oder eine Angeborene sein, eine Intoleranz sein, eine Unverträglichkeit sein.
Und vielleicht ein Zusammenhang mit einem Kohlenhydrat oder Glythin könnte es sein.
Mit was?
Ja, diese Beschwerden sind verbunden mit einem Glythin oder einem Nahrungsmittel.
Ja, das müsste man vielleicht mal gucken.
Aber ja, wie ich gesagt habe, vielleicht erkläre ich Ihnen, was wir weitergehen wollen.
Als würde ich jetzt Ihren Sohn körperlich untersuchen, dann Blutentnahme durchführen,
dann einige technische Untersuchungen wie zum Beispiel Bauchultraschall durchführen.
Das tut aber nicht weh, oder?
Ja, ganz genau.
Es tut nicht weh und sehr schmerzfrei und auch nicht röntgenfrei und sehr riskolos.
Dann bitte nehmen Sie Platz im Wartesma, dann rufen Sie auf wieder.
Okay.
Ja, möchte ich von den Kolleginnen noch jemand zusätzliche Fragen stellen?
Darf ich?
Ja, gerne.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Ihr Sohn chronisch durchfällt und wässrig ist.
Aber ich möchte lernen. Ich würde gerne wissen.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass die gemäßlichen Unvergleichbarkeiten zum Beispiel Brot oder Kohlenhydrate enthalten,
z.B. Brot oder andere Dementsmittel?
Das, was die Auslöser sind, meinen Sie, oder was?
Ja, ja.
Das habe ich nicht beobachtet. Neulich, als es ganz schlimm war, hatten wir vorher Ludeln gegessen.
Das wären ja Kohlenhydrate.
Danke schön.
Ja, genau.
Was geht?
Weiß ich nicht. Also ich habe keine Angaben dazu.
Ich habe keine Angaben zum weiteren Verlauf dieser Zuckerkrankheit, leider.
Und es steht nichts im Fall.
Müsste ich jetzt mir aus den Fingern saugen, kann ich aber nicht.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass innerhalb von sechs Monaten, dass er ca. zwei oder drei Kilo abgenommen hat.
Früher hatte er schon ähnliche Beschwerden, z.B. vor zwei Jahren.
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
So etwas kann ich nicht. Sonst wäre ich ja schon früher zum Arzt gegangen.
Das ist jetzt neu. Ich habe das auf die Geschichte mit der Scheidung und der familiären Situation zurückgeführt.
Aber es scheint irgendwie noch andere Gründe zu haben.
Mit sieben Jahren kann er alles gegessen, oder?
Aber er ist halt ein schlechter Esser. Nein, das ist das Problem.
Er mag nicht gerne Obst und Gemüse. Er mag keinen Salat.
Ich muss ihm immer sehr überreden, dass er irgendwas gesundes ist.
Kann es losgehen?
Guten Abend, Frau Wichmann.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen, den ich vorstellen würde.
Hätten Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, wen haben Sie gesehen?
Wir würden das Aufnahmegespräch der Mutter von dem Patienten erhoben.
Wir haben mit...
Ja.
Das war eine Anamnese, ja?
Ja, das Aufnahmegespräch.
Also die Mutter war mit Ihrem Kind da?
Ja, die Mutter von dem Patienten erhoben.
Die Mutter...
Ja, die heißt Elisabeth Engel und unser Patient heißt Marvin Engel.
Er ist 9 Jahre alt, 15.02.2017 geboren.
Und so seit er 1,31 Meter groß und 28 Kilogramm schwer ist.
Und der Patient wurde in unserer Klinik wegen seit etwa halbem Jahr bestehender Prognose,
wässriger Dürre sowie Abdominalschmerzen vorstellig.
Laut Angaben der Mutter vom Patienten...
Ja, ich hoffe, ich muss erst mal...
Sie haben diese Dürre zwei bis viermal täglich aufgetreten und beschrieben sie als schleimig, heller und ganz festlich.
Und begleitend habe der Patient Gewichtverlust von 3 Kilogramm innerhalb von...
Ja, kein Wunder, wenn er immer Durchfall hat, ja.
Und er habe unter Möglichkeit und einer Konzentrationsstörung und ausgeprägte Erflutung gelitten.
Und...
Er habe gelitten, also jetzt nicht mehr? Er leidet immer noch darunter, oder?
Er leidet immer noch unter Erflutung, Konzentrationsstörung und Asthenie.
Und die Abdominalschmerzen waren drückend.
Und hat seine Mutter nicht über die Stärke oder die Intensität genannt.
In der vegetativen Anamnese ergab sich folgende Befunden.
In der Apathens-Diorabdingte Schlafstörung in der Sonne und eine Polydipsy... Polykisserie.
Und er leidet an Diabetes mellitus ein und dagegen spritzt er Insulin.
Und er leidet auch ein Examen in oberen Armbereich und trägt eine Salbe auf.
Und er...
Wie lange hat er das schon?
Ja schon noch.
Das Examen?
Ja, in einem juckenden Examen. Ich denke ein Atompische oder vielleicht...
Aber wie lange hat er das schon? Seit wann hat er das?
Ja, seit wann? Schon in letzter Zeit, aber habe ich ganz genau nicht verstanden.
Er ist wegen einer Hengenal-Hernetomie-Operation vor zwei Jahren durchgeführt worden.
Bei ihm?
Bei ihm, bei ihm durchgeführt worden. Und seine Mutter hat eine Gallenstein gelitten.
Und sein Vater hat eine arteriäre Hypertonie, die im Status vollständig ist.
Und Reise an Amnese ist negativ.
Er hat einen Bruder und befindet sich in einer Familie. Er lebt mit seiner Mutter.
Und schon geschieden hat.
Oder? Die schon geschieden hat.
Die schon geschieden ist. Also die Mutter ist geschieden.
Und er lebt bei der Mutter, ne?
Ja, er lebt bei der Mutter.
Gut, und was ist Ihre Vermutung?
Ja, aufgrund der bisherigen Angaben ergibt sich hier ein Verdacht auf Sullyaki.
Und...
Könnte es differenzial diagnostisch noch sein?
Eine Laktoseintoleranz oder vielleicht Fructoseintoleranz oder eine Dasturoenteritis.
Oder eine Hypertriose wegen dieser Haarausfall oder Gewichtsabnahme.
Ah ja, ok.
Konzentration stört.
Was haben wir noch? Wir haben noch zwei Autoimmunerkrankungen, die man ins Kölkü ziehen sollte.
Autoimmun... ja...
Habe ich es so gesagt... ja... Mopskrum... könnte es sein.
Und?
Konzentration der Darmerkrankung, aber ja...
In der Kulitonentropathie...
Ja, das wäre ja Sullyaki, ne?
Kolitis uterosa möglicherweise, ne?
Ja, Kolitis uterosa auch, ja.
Ja, Kolitis ist möglich.
Hat Blut genannt, aber ja, das ist auch unmöglich, ja.
Für Mopskrum ist es...
Kann man sprechen.
Und was machen Sie denn jetzt diagnostisch mit dem Kind?
Ja, wie die...
Ich würde erst die Vitalparameter erheben.
Ja, einschließlich Herzfrequenz, Atemfrequenz und Temperatur auch.
Ja, mögliche Entzündung.
Und danach würde ich eine Blutentnahme durchführen.
Ja, es...
Machen Sie nicht erstmal eine körperliche Untersuchung, eine Inspektion?
Ja, genau. Ja, natürlich. Ich würde erst das körperliche untersuchen, damit einem nicht...
Worauf achten wie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Was ist Ihr Augenmerk? Worauf achten Sie?
Ja, bei der körperlichen Untersuchung, ich fokussiere auf den Bauch.
Bei der Untersuchung mit einem Schrittweise betrachte ich danach eine Papiere und auskultiere ich ob die Darmgeräusche gerecht sind.
Ob die Darmgeräusche gerecht sind, ja.
Sind, aha.
Und ob auch Druckschmerz, Abwärtsspannung oder mögliche Entzündungszeichen wie ein Abhandenssitz oder so.
Aber es geht um eine Durchfälligkeit. Ja, natürlich.
Und...
Aber auch betrachte ich den Haar und auch die Hautveränderungen in allen Körper...
Wichtig, ja. Genau.
Ja, richtig. Ja, natürlich eine Organe möglich hat der Patient oder...
Also das machen Sie beim Tasten, merken Sie ob da irgendwas geschwollen ist, ja? Gut.
Und danach, was machen Sie dann? Sie sagten Blut abnehmen, ja?
So habe ich gesagt, ja, wie es ein großes Blut, ein kleines Blut bildet und Entzündungsparameter, CRP, WSG und ja, und Prokasten auch manchmal dann, ja, Nierenwerte und mögliche ABs, AA1c und ja, Glukose.
Genau, wegen des Diabetes, ja.
Ja, Nierenwerte auch und ja, einige Antikore. Antikörper, ja, genau.
Was erwarten Sie denn? Was erwarten Sie denn aus dem Labor nach Ihrer Verdachtsdiagnose?
Ich bin der Ansicht, ja, der Patient hat eine erhöhte BSG-Werte und auch Antikörper, aber zurzeit ist mir nicht erinnerlich.
Ja, wir haben nicht einen und...
Gut. Ja, was machen Sie weiter, wenn Sie Blut abgenommen haben? Was machen Sie noch für Untersuchungen mit dem Patienten?
Ja, der Patient sollte unbedingt mit Sonographie untersucht werden, auch unter Schad und ob ein Darmgeruch oder alle Organe gut betrachtet werden können.
Ja, danach bei diesem Patienten empfehle ich eine Magenspegel-Koloskopie durchführen lassen. Ja, ich werde durchführen lassen.
Ja, dann eine Gewerbeprobe oder Entnehmen, das ist sehr sicherlich ein Gottstandard für die Diagnose.
Ja, genau, sehr gut. Gut. Wenn sich Ihre Diagnose bestätigt, was wäre denn die Therapie für diesen kleinen Patienten?
Ja, ganz sicher hier eine Verzichtung der glutenenthaltigen Nahrungsmittel.
Also eine Verzichtung auf glutenhaltige Nahrungsmittel, also eine glutenfreie Kost.
Ja, und eine Subvention der Vitamine, ja, vielleicht ein bisschen Eisen und die anderen Vitamine im Fett, lösliche Vitamine A, D, E, K.
Sehr gut, ja, okay. Was darf er denn noch essen? Was darf die Mutter ihm denn noch zu essen geben?
Was darf? Welche Nahrungsmittel enthalten Gluten und welche enthalten Wein?
Ja, eine Kohlenhydrate, zum Beispiel Brot und auch, wie kann man genau beschreiben, kann ich nicht vielleicht das sagen, aber glutenhaltige ist Kohlenhydrate, aber das ist weißer.
Die Getreidearten, ja, wir haben doch die Getreidearten, Weizen, Robben, Hafer, sind alle glutenhaltig.
Ja, gut. Was darf er essen? Er darf Reis essen, er darf Kartoffeln essen und er darf natürlich Fleisch essen, klar.
Ja, Kartoffeln enthalten auch, glaube ich, kein Gluten. Also er muss ja nicht kohlenhydratfrei sich ernähren, er darf nur keine glutenhaltigen Sachen essen.
Gut, ja, aber Sie haben natürlich genau richtig gesagt, dass er eine Vitaminsubstitution braucht und Sie haben was gesagt, was ich vorher eigentlich hören wollte.
Sie haben gesagt, man muss wahrscheinlich Eisen substituieren. Das ist eigentlich noch so eine Erwartung bei den Laborwerten, dass der mit den Eisenwerten unten ist.
Dass der keine guten Eisenwerte hat. Wahrscheinlich sieht das Kind auch ein bisschen blass aus.
Ja, wir sind schon mitten in der Diskussion. Fachlich haben Sie sich, glaube ich, wirklich sehr, sehr gut geschlagen.
Sie haben, es war natürlich dafür, dass Sie am Donnerstag Prüfung haben, war das natürlich gemein, dass Sie jetzt eine Fremdananese machen mussten.
Weiß nicht, gibt es das bei Ihnen in Brandenburg? Gibt es Fremdananese?
Nicht so viel eigentlich bisher. Ja, einige Fälle, vereinzelte Fälle.
Ich habe auch nur zwei Fallbeispiele mit Fremdananese. Ja, hat Sie es also gerade erwischt.
Ja, gut. Das ist zugegeben ein bisschen schwer, weil Sie nicht so standardmäßig fragen können, wie Sie das in einem normalen Notfall machen würden.
Ja, das ist ein Subjekt immer verwechselt in meinem Kopf. Es ist ungewöhnlich und natürlich sehr schwer für mich.
Ja, das gebe ich zu, dass das sehr erschwerte Bedingungen waren.
Man kann eben nicht diesen Fragenkatalog so runterspulen, wie wir den gewöhnt sind von erwachsenen Patienten, sondern beim Kind.
Ja, Sie haben das selber gemerkt, dass es abwegig ist, nach Rauchen und Alkohol zu fragen.
Also ein Neunjähriger, der jeden Abend eine Flasche Bier trinkt, wäre extrem ungewöhnlich, würde ich mal sagen.
Ja, das ist halt völlig andere Kategorie.
Was mir so ein bisschen gefehlt hat, das war in Ihrem, in Ihrer Wiedergabe, also in Ihrem Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch,
dass Sie auf diese familiäre Belastungssituation eingegangen sind.
Ja, und dass die Mutter das eigentlich so als Entschuldigung so ein bisschen genommen hat, warum sie nicht eher zum Arzt gegangen ist.
Ja, das Ehepaar ist geschieden. Die Mutter ist nicht geschieden, sondern die Eltern sind geschieden.
Ja, und natürlich ist eine Scheidung eine große Belastungssituation für Kinder, psychische Belastung.
Und die Vermutung der Mutter war ja, das nervt den alles so, deswegen mag er nicht in die Schule gehen, deswegen tut er, als ob er krank ist.
Das ist ja so ein bisschen der Hintergrund. Und das haben Sie gar nicht vermittelt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie es nicht rausgehört haben, ob Sie es nicht gemerkt haben, dass die Mutter versucht hat, das damit zu erklären.
Ja, ich habe es schon zweimal gesagt, dass er Stressfaktoren hat und diese Scheidungsprozess und vielleicht eine Ursache hat, eine Hindernis.
Ja, genau, dass das vielleicht so eine psychosomatische Stresskrise auch vielleicht bewirken kann.
Die Mutter hat ja die Schilderung am Anfang, hat ja gesagt, er will nur nicht in die Schule gehen.
Und insofern, das hätte ich ganz gerne noch gehört als Oberärztin, dass es eben dieses Problem gibt.
Und ja, das ist eine Geschichte. Wir haben ein bisschen Verständigungsprobleme gehabt, die waren zum Teil aber auch durch die Verbindung.
Ich hatte zwischendurch so ganz kleine Aussetzer im Internet. Ich konnte zwischendurch so kleine Bröckchen nicht verstehen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es den anderen anders gegangen ist, aber da war die Kommunikation manchmal nicht so ganz erst rein.
Und es gibt aber auch ein bisschen Probleme, sie sehr gut zu verstehen.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, dass sie ziemlich oft das, was wir alle machen, äh, sagen.
Wir machen das alle, kein Stress, wir machen das alle, aber sie machen das schon extrem häufig.
Das ist ein bisschen signifikant. Das werden sie jetzt bis zur Prüfung nicht abstellen können.
Keine Ahnung. Ja, so. Was man einfach sagen muss, dass sie dafür, dass sie so eine schwierige Situation hatten,
dass sie in dieser ungewöhnlichen Kommunikation waren. Also praktisch über die fremde Person den Zugriff auf den Patienten.
Also auch das ist ja wiederum eine nicht ganz echte typische Situation.
Ein neunjähriges Kind kann man ja fragen, wie stark sind deine Schmerzen?
Ja, und dann hat man vielleicht keine numerische Skala, sondern man hat dann eben irgendwie so Grinsegesichter, die zwischen Mh und Mh gehen.
Und dann kann man das praktisch analogisieren.
Das Kind ist ja nicht stumm daneben. Das hört ja mit und könnte ja auch was sagen.
Aber das kriegen wir halt in der Simulation nicht hin. Ich habe hier keinen neunjährigen neben mir.
Oder ich müsste so, ja, ich habe aber ganz tolle Schmerzen. Dann müsste ich also auch noch das Kind spielen.
Das kriegen wir jetzt nicht hin.
Vielleicht ja der neunjährige Sohn, ja, ein Patient, dieser Patient kann auch sprechen, ja, seine Beschwerden gut erzählen können.
Er kann gut umsehen und ja etwas nennen über die, ja, ich habe Bauchschmerzen und solche.
Ja, ja, das würde er natürlich sagen.
Ich habe mich nicht gefragt, ob eine nicht ansprechbar oder ich weiß nicht, so eine schlechte Situation hat.
Nein, das ist eigentlich nur der Situation geschuldet, dass wir hier, also ich hätte sonst noch das Kind spielen müssen, ja.
Also klar kann ein neunjähriger auch vernünftige Antworten geben.
Da kann man da, hattest du keine Lust in die Schule zu gehen?
Das auch nicht, aber so, ja, hätte der vielleicht gesagt, ja.
Aber sie sind ja sehr zielstrebig eigentlich drauf losgegangen.
Sie haben ja eigentlich sehr schnell gemerkt, in welche Richtung das geht, dass das auf die Zylarkie hingeht.
Und da waren sie dann ja auch nachher im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch bei den Diagnoseverfahren.
Was sie machen müssen, da waren sie ja auch sehr sicher.
Und was ich Ihnen jetzt anbieten möchte noch, das wäre Folgendes, dass Sie, wenn Sie doch jetzt Ihren Arztbrief schreiben müssen, ja,
dass Sie heute Abend noch oder morgen früh, oder wenn Sie Zeit haben, mir schnell Ihren Arztbrief schreiben, so wie Sie ihn schreiben würden.
Nicht über KI laufen lassen, ja, also nicht eine Schreibkorrektur drin. Das haben Sie in der Prüfung auch nicht.
Dass Sie mir den Brief so schreiben und mir den per E-Mail schicken, dann könnte ich ihn korrigieren und zurückschicken.
Dass wir noch einmal diese schriftliche Korrektur haben. Wenn Sie das wollen, ist ein Angebot.
Wenn das in Brandenburg tatsächlich ein Teil der Prüfung ist, könnten wir das noch sozusagen nachsimulieren.
Das kann ich Ihnen anbieten, dann hätten Sie noch praktisch eine zusätzliche Sicherheit.
Und wenn dann noch irgendwelche sprachlichen Unklaren sind, könnten wir das bei der Gelegenheit, dann praktisch könnte ich Ihnen da eine Rückmeldung geben.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie es machen wollen, ob Sie Zeit haben, das zu tun und ob Sie Lust haben, das zu tun.
Es ist natürlich extra Arbeit nochmal.
Ja, aber ja.
Brauchen Sie meine E-Mail-Anschrift? Dr. Pupil, haben Sie meine E-Mail?
Leider, ich habe keine.
Sie haben keine?
Aber ich kann Dr. Mahmoud...
Der hat die. Dr. Gündis hat die. Aber dann sage ich Ihnen die einfach. Sie lesen ja meinen Namen hier, den können Sie lesen.
So, gerhild.wichmann.gmail.com.
Das ist meine E-Mail-Anschrift.
Haben Sie?
Ja, ja, ihr habt die E-Mail-Anschrift.
Dann könnte Frau Doktor mir Ihren Arztbrief schicken und ich schicke Ihnen den Korrigier zurück, also per E-Mail schicken.
Ok?
Der Ausschlag an den Armen hat die Mutter gesagt, das hat er seit zwei Wochen.
Und ja, dann eben diese Geschichte.
Ja, die Mutter hat eigentlich auf Nachfrage gesagt, die Durchfälle sind eher wässrig als schleimig.
Und Sie haben schleimig als erstes gesagt.
Gut, ja.
Was Sie der Oberärztin auch glaube ich nicht gesagt haben, keine Blutbeinmängungen.
Das haben Sie glaube ich nicht erwähnt, ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Keine Blut dabei.
War kein Blut drin, hat die Mutter gesagt. Und ich glaube, das haben Sie im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch nicht erwähnt.
Und ja, also der Klassiker, verschlechtert nach einem Nudelessen.
Ja, also da ist man eigentlich schon auf der richtigen Schiene.
Gut.
Ja, und was ich mir jetzt noch angekringelt hatte, das war diese familiäre Situation,
dass die Kinder bei der Mutter leben und die Eltern geschieden sind.
Dass das also so eine spezielle Extra-Situation ist, die möglicherweise für alle Beteiligten so eine psychische Belastungssituation darstellt.
Das hätte ich mir wie gesagt noch gewünscht in dem Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Aber wie gesagt, das war jetzt Ihr persönliches Pech, dass Sie in diese Fremdanamnese reingeraten sind.
Das ist extrem schwierig. Ich hoffe, es ist nicht zu demotivierend für Sie.
Gut, und ansonsten, wie gesagt, wenn Sie mir das schicken, schicke ich es Ihnen zurück.
Und ansonsten werden wir Ihnen mit vereinten Kräften alle Mann am Donnerstag die Daumen halten.
Damit das ganz gut klappt bei der Prüfung.